Daniel,
how to be a good partner to someone suffering from depression.
That's a tough one,
man.
It's very hard to live with someone who's suffering from depression.
We are helping without enabling and pushing without being too judgmental.
Well,
again,
the devil's in the details.
Is the person seeing a counselor because if they're depressed,
then they need to talk to someone.
Have they tried antidepressants?
Because if they're depressed,
they should try antidepressants.
Okay.
And they should be strongly encouraged to do so.
And maybe that encouragement should even border on a demand because depression
is just,
it's terrible.
It's terrible for the person who's experiencing it,
like unalterably terrible.
Um,
and it's terrible for the person who is living with the person who has
depression.
And so it's incumbent on the person who has depression to do everything they
possibly can in order to set it straight.
And it's hard.
But you know,
there's lots of potential treatments for depression that have some efficacy in
antidepressants.
Really do work wonders on people.
You could try five hydroxy tryptamine too.
You could look that up.
Five HTP,
it's usually three times a hundred milligrams.
Um,
and you can,
if you try that,
sometimes you can find out if antidepressants will work for you without having
to resort to the antidepressants themselves.
Um,
you can also help the depressed person make a plan in the morning.
That can be really useful or maybe a plan the night before if they're just not
in any shape to do it in the morning,
to sit down and say,
okay,
well you have to get through tomorrow.
And that's another good,
that's another good piece of advice.
And so in rule 12,
I talk about that sometimes in relationship to depression,
real 12 is pet a cat when you encounter one on the street.
And it's a bit of a meditation about what to do when your life is in absolute
crisis.
But one of the things you can do with someone who's depressed is narrow.
And this is what I discuss in this chapter is narrow their timeframe.
You know,
maybe a depressed person can't think a week ahead,
but maybe they can think about tomorrow and you can sit down and say,
okay,
well you have to get through tomorrow.
And so how are we going to structure tomorrow so that it will be okay and so
that you'll be able to sleep reasonably soundly when you go to bed tomorrow
night.
And then tomorrow night we'll do the same thing.
And helping someone come up with a daily plan can be,
now they might object and squawk and complain about it,
but you should be.
Um,
I would say relatively persistent about that.
And you can say,
look,
let's just try it for a week.
And if they say no,
then you say,
well,
let's try it for one day.
You know,
Christ,
the person's got to be pretty unreasonable if they,
let's plan for 10 minutes just for tomorrow,
and see if that's helpful.
You know,
if the person objects,
you can keep cutting the magnitude of what you're asking down until you finally
get a bit of a,
a bit of an agreement from them.
But helping someone depressed plan can help a lot.